like to welcome our first speaker dr.
Harry Auster he runs the is the director
of the human genome program human
genetics program at NYU Medical School
he is a professor of pediatrics
pathology and medicine there and he's a
wide range of interests which he's
pursued in his laboratory he's worked on
the genetics of prostate cancer and
other forms of cancer he's worked on
genetics of ancestry particularly in
Jewish and Latino populations he's
worked on the genetics of male sexual
development and he's been very involved
in issues involving the fair use of
genetic information and in that capacity
he's been an advisor to the National
Institutes of Health has been advisor
the Defense Department and the New York
Bar Association here in New York in
which he's been involved in every piece
of legislation that's pending or enacted
that has to do with genetic testing with
reproductive technology and human
cloning so welcome dr. Auster
so I'd like to thank Paul Hoffman and
his fellow organizers of big think for
inviting me to participate this evening
as Francis Collins understudied this
invitation has left me wondering what
whether there might be an NIH
directorship in my future or whether
I'll be left with the happy fate of
being a medical geneticist free to
pursue my own research leads there are
three areas that I currently explore the
first is the genetic control of male
sexual development normally a switch on
the Y chromosome turns on a pathway that
causes half of us in the population to
develop testes male reproductive
structures and to develop as men but the
switch or its downstream relays may go
awry causing affected individuals to
develop as women or to have ambiguous
sexual development these people with
disorders of sexual development present
the experiments of nature that we
geneticists so value because they
represent an opportunity for
understanding the whole cascade of genes
in the male sexual development pathway
in my lab we've recently identified one
of these regulatory genes for male
sexual development and we think that it
is not a relay for the master regulator
rather it regulates the on switch for
the master regulator we study the
populations of Jewish and Hispanic
Latino people together these groups
comprise twelve and twenty percent of
the population of New York City we're
tracing the Jewish Diaspora back and
forth across the Mediterranean Basin
into Europe and into the new world Jews
form their own distinctive genetic
clusters with each group of the Diaspora
forming its own sub cluster Puerto
Ricans and Dominicans are for the most
part the variable descendants of
Europeans and Africans whereas Mexicans
Ecuadorians and Colombians are the
descendants of Native Americans and
Europeans we're using methods that
recognize this
mixed ancestry to map genes for traits
such as susceptibility to breast cancer
in fact my nyu collaborators and i are
working to develop predictive genetic
tests for breast prostate and prostate
cancers as well as melanoma envisioning
a day perhaps five years hence when it
will be possible to perform a test in
which the results will be reproducible
in meaningful if we thought that the
tests that are offered by
direct-to-consumer genetic testing
companies were valid then we would use
them at our cancer genetics risk
evaluation program where we see nearly a
thousand people each year assessing
their risks of breast ovarian and colon
cancers when a new genetic test is
introduced into clinical practice we're
looking for three things analytical
validity clinical validity and clinical
utility the tests that are performed in
my clinical genetics laboratory and in
the other laboratories that I use to
assess the risk for my patients at NYU
meet all of these criteria let's look at
each of these in turn analytical
validity is the ability of a test to
accurately and reliably measure the
genotype of interest for many DNA chips
the call rates are in the range of 98 to
99.9 percent that sounds great but let's
throw in some numbers this means on a
DNA chip with the million probes 1,000
to 20,000 results are being missed
that's okay in my research lab but it
sure isn't in my clinical lab where I
have to guarantee to the patients into
the Department of Health that I can
provide complete results to every
patient now let's throw in the recent
computer software and we learn from
shrikant Monty who runs the DNA chip
core facility at Yale that the false
positive rate is one percent this is a
false positive rate anywhere on the chip
not in the probe for breast cancer or
type 2 diabetes my patients in the
Department of Health would say well dr.
Auster that just isn't good enough
so what about clinical validity this is
the ability of a test to detect or
predict the associated disorder it must
be great now why else would these
directing consumer companies be offering
testing to consumers Jeffrey Drazen the
editor the New England Journal of
Medicine has written even the ardent
proponents of genetic susceptibility
testing would argue it would agree that
for most diseases we are still at the
early stages of identifying the full
list of susceptibility associated
variance we know from research studies
that most common diseases diabetes
various cancers and heart disease are
caused by multiple gene variants acting
together and with environmental factors
the studies that are now identifying
these factors and their interactions are
only now being conducted in their
validation for clinical use will come
later as you will hear from a fellow
panelist no two companies can agree on
her risk of disease boggers who have
used direct-to-consumer genetic testing
have written about how their diabetes or
colon cancer was not predicted by the
DNA chip kenneth 'it the head of cancer
genetics at memorial sloan-kettering
Cancer Center has written the companies
offered often state that the services
offered are not medical tests but they
are provided for informational purposes
only but seriously folks if you learn
that you were at increased risk for
heart attack or colon cancer or type 2
diabetes wouldn't you want to discuss
this with your doctor it wouldn't you
feel rather foolish when he said but
seriously Ted let's not make too much
out of this or would he start ordering
tests a stress EKG colonoscopy a glucose
tolerance test to follow up on the false
positive results that are the bane of
physicians practices this raises the
third issue of clinical utility or the
balance of associated risks and benefits
Jeffrey Drazen from the New England
Journal has written this is the arena
and what
they're virtually no data on the health
impact of genome-wide analysis there are
very few observational studies and
almost no clinical trials that
demonstrate the risks and benefits
associated with screening for individual
gene variants let alone testing for many
hundreds of thousands of variants and
what might we do and what might those
recommendations be lose weight eat
better stop smoking exercise more who
needs a thousand-dollar genetic test to
tell her to engage in lifestyle changes
that will have broad health effects
suppose she learns she is at increased
risk for breast cancer as women who are
brca1 carriers do would she take drugs
that would put her into menopause or
have her breasts removed to lower the
risk would she just worry her way from
one mammogram to the next so what can we
do now that is reasonable get diagnosed
if you have a genetic disease get
treated and learn about it knowledge is
power learn about your family history if
based on your family history you are at
high risk for colon cancer heart disease
blood clots or host of other conditions
consult with the medical geneticist
there may be a specific genetic test
that is appropriate for you get carrot
carrier testing before marriage before
pregnancy during pregnancy get the other
tests that are appropriate for people in
your stage of the life cycle learn your
wrists and act you don't need a
thousand-dollar genetic test to spur you
into action now the purveyors of
direct-to-consumer genetic testing would
say that this is the old fashioned
neanderthal what I'd practice of medical
genetics but I would beg to differ we
medical geneticists and genetic
counselors are the age of progress of
genetic discovery we have reinvented our
profession many times and we are leading
the way to discovering the analytical
validity the clinical validity and the
clinical utility of new genetic tests we
admire the community activism
that brought us new treatments for
hiv/aids expanded genetic screening for
breast cancer via mammography and
validated new genetic testing for many
conditions we want to build a bridge to
somewhere we're looking forward to that
day when a 61 year old man walks into
our office with a pill rolling trimmer
and we can insert his DNA sequence micro
disk into our genetic risk reader and it
will stay with high likelihood that he
has Parkinson disease type 7 moreover it
will tell us that he would benefit from
treatment with drug see because of his
personal risk benefit genetic ratio that
day is not far off and it will be coming
one disease at a time in the meantime I
fear that the purveyors of
direct-to-consumer genetic testing where
their faulty claims will scare away our
patients and betray the public's trust
in medical genetics thank you very much
for listening